any of them that are land-based we can
go take them over there's more of us I
think these are very penetrable the ones
that are totally locked away they're
agriculture systems are totally
self-contained have you ever seen
somebody doing vertical farming at home
you get a bad batch you just take it out
and go build another one you can't do
that when you're locked away what do you
do you go out with a crew with a couple
of guys with machine guns to run and
find some more sterile topsoil but of
course you got the nuclear fallout and
the zombies and the Killer Bees and
whatever it is out there that you're
supposed to be hiding from
it seems to me the kind of an
inevitability I've had a lot of
conversations on the show about
existential risk talking about the work
of people like Toby ORD and Nick Bostrom
are we going to get turned into gray goo
or a big bunch of paper clips you know
this small background risk of a gamma
burst destroying us all or is the polar
the polar ends gonna flip and then all
of the technology is going to fall out
it seems unsurprising to me that the
people that have the absolute most
resources on the planet who are exposed
to this kind of thinking who are
probably technologists in one form or
another techno-utopians would take that
run with it and think I essentially have
an unlimited number of resources
how can I try and insulate myself from
this problem that to me doesn't seem
very surprising at all
no but I wonder what the order of events
really is is it oh I've got all these
resources so I have a lot of stuff
that's at risk and I want to spend a lot
of my energy protecting myself or is it
I've achieved my great wealth and all my
technological monopolies and stuff by
treating other people and places as if
the world is already ending so I really
like to have some evidence that the
world is ending so I can justify having
essentially used a bomb shelter
mentality all along
how would you say millionaires have
treated the world as if it was already
ending billionaires have treated the
world as if it was already ending from
before now
well
I mean there's so many examples like one
I just heard was on um
uh a piece that Corey doctorow a friend
of mine wrote about uh Epson printers
and apparently they make a certain Epson
printer is pre-programmed to Brick
itself after a certain number of pages
and he interviewed the company to find
out why and they Justified that there's
a tiny little sponge somewhere in this
printer that absorbs the loose dust and
after however many five or ten thousand
Pages they believe that that little
sponge might be filled up and some of
the Dust might sprinkle out onto the
filing cabinet or the piece of paper
under which you've yep where you put the
printer and to prevent that disaster
from happening and because you can't
replace that two cent sponge I mean my
God that would be an impossible feat of
administration they will save us all by
breaking the the printer and forcing you
to throw it into a waste pile somewhere
you know a big toxic waste pile that
some Brazilian children pick at to find
the renewable you know rare earth metals
in it and then send some other children
to get the rare earth metals out of a
mine to build a new printer for you now
the guy at Epson who makes that decision
is not stupid he knows I am contributing
to climate change I'm contributing to
the end of the world by doing this but
I'm going to make enough margin selling
an extra few printers that I'm going to
be able to distance myself from the
reality I'm creating by earning money in
this way so this series of decisions
that are made or the guy the guy I spoke
to at one of those uh uh boot camps who
uh was one of the guys who put the
algorithms in the social media feeds
that addict teenagers to uh uh you know
clicking and whatever and worrying about
themselves
doesn't let his kids touch this stuff
he's got a private you know uh uh
organic farm with a goat share his kid
goes to a Rudolph Steiner School and is
not allowed to touch anything so he's
already got a kind of organic farm
bunker in the middle of nowhere and
behaving as if everyone else's kids are
the ones who are being left behind so if
you've got an apocalypse coming you can
kind of say okay that's why
I'm doing it this way
um okay so you're saying that a a large
apocalypse justifies this sort of
zero-sum
me and mine versus [ __ ] everybody else
that sort of mentality is is born out of
that on the one hand yeah and I guess on
the other hand what I'm looking at is
this just a sort of uh uh innate techno
geek nerd and I share it sometimes too
fear of women and nature and
unpredictable stuff and a lot of us who
got involved in Tech from the very
beginning liked it because it kind of
creates a bit of order I remember when
uh I was with Timothy Leary when he was
reading uh media lab the book by Stuart
brand about Nicholas negroponte's oh
mit's got this big thing called media
lab it was really the first place where
they were building all the you know
computers the first place to look at
digital Marvin Minsky was there and Ai
and and Stuart brand wrote this book
about the the media lab and I was with
Timothy Leary when he was reading it
he's circling everything with Flare pens
and I'm thinking oh he loves all this
talk about the digital future and
anti-aliasing and and robot
Consciousness and all and when he's done
with the book he goes blood and he
throws it across the room like it says
sorry and he goes first up only two
percent of the names in the index are
women you know that's how you know
they've got a problem then he said and
second these guys are trying to recreate
the womb they their mothers were unable
to anticipate their every need and now
they want to build this this
technological bubble where they can sit
and have algorithms and robots you know
bring to them what they want before they
even know they want it and so there's
that kind of fantasy that goes along
with the perfect Tech solution that that
again an apocalypse is a really good uh
justification for for wanting to to
build that private uh you know private
Sanctuary uh it's kind of like
permanently existing in a science
fiction novel that has probably inspired
a ton of the work that you've done talk
to me about talk to me about what
spending time with Timothy Leary was
like
I was it was great and a little bit
horrible at the same time you know being
with Timothy Leary was kind of like
being on acid you know kind of like
being an asset or well yes it was being
on us
sometimes it was but he got acid but
sometimes it was just like being on acid
so it was um uh a beautiful Zone in some
ways but it was unforgiving it was like
it he would he would play
um kind of dominant psychologist with
you all the time you know reflecting
back to you whatever he saw as uh uh
you know a Neurosis or an impediment to
whatever you were you know just say it
what come on you know and it was geez
just can't you chill so the social Moors
the sort of typical things that people
would be allowed to just let slide
Timothy would decide to point the finger
at it and call out the elephant in the
room right so it was a it was sometimes
a taxing
um I have some friends I have some
friends that are like that yeah
yeah I mean I I get it you know no no no
compromise especially you know and I
knew him by the time I knew him he was
already in his 60s and probably thinking
I don't have time
for anything but you know and if you and
if you did treat you like that it's
because he considered you a friend you
know someone who would come in a lot of
times famous people would come into the
house like an Oliver Stone or Eliza
Minnelli or someone and do stuff that
was obviously kind of of silly or
egotistical or something and he wouldn't
say anything until they were gone
because he didn't see I also because
they're high status people you don't
just tell Oliver Stone I don't want to
do your freaking Ayahuasca that you
brought in from South America in a
bottle I don't know what that is
you know it was it was sort of that
funny okay so when it comes to
billionaires and how they've been
preparing I mean I've seen
an absolute ton of Articles over the
last
five years I would say mostly uh the
Farmland that's being purchased in
Middle America
um New Zealand seems to be one of the
most popular places uh sea studying
um these opportunities for people to air
gap themselves from society in one form
or another obviously we've potentially
got you know multi-planetary species not
a million years away from now happening
uh how did you get introduced to
thinking about this seriously
I mean
I don't know if seriously is the right
word but certainly thinking about it was
um uh this uh talk that I was supposed
to give to um some you know wealthy Tech
investors they hired me like they hire
people like us basically they think
understand something about the future
um because we said something they didn't
understand once they go oh that must be
a futurist
um so they hired me to do a talk about
the digital future out in the middle of
the desert you know it's a big money
thing so I went you know as I subsidized
my my thinking with uh whatever that is
these these kind of hired intellectual
dominatrix sessions
you standing there full leather outfit
with a whip and everything but it's a
what instead of you hitting anyone it's
just you gesturing with a whiteboard
behind you I could see that yeah really
no my PhD is my whip right
but uh
I'm out there to do this
do the talker miking me up they bring
these Five Guys into the green room and
they sit around this little table and
start peppering me with all these
questions about the future and you know
when it started out the regular binary
Tech investor questions you know Bitcoin
ethereum virtual reality augmented
reality you know and I'm not the person
to ask that either I would have said
betamax instead of VHS you know I would
have said CompuServe instead of AOL I'm
always wrong because I picked the better
thing not the one that's gonna win right
Myspace whatever Myspace gives us more
it's better it gives us more we can do
or pick our own backgrounds you know or
HTML I would have said you know just
like I don't need freaking you know
WordPress
um so I'm always wrong with that I'm
right about the big picture but always
wrong about which company to bet on but
anyway so they're doing that with me and
then finally one of the guys says uh so
uh Alaska or New Zealand and then the
rest of the thing rest of the time was
them uh peppering me with questions and
asking me about you know how to how to
survive and I was I was really shocked
and started really asking them more
questions than they were asked asking me
like all right so how are you going to
deal with you know germs and where are
you going to get your water and are you
going to have your own fresh water
supply you're going to be depending on
uh underground water that's being
contaminated by whatever happened in the
outside world how are you going to guard
yourselves and then they said that they
hired Navy Seals to come fly in
and it's interesting because it's always
Navy Seals that say nobody picks Army
Rangers it's like for my Movie
experience I like Army Rangers
especially if you're on the ground if
you're not sea studying I want army guys
right they're great if something feels
more I don't know I like them I I like
their their media image their movie
their movie image better than Navy Seals
for me in terms of my protection but all
of them had Navy Seals I don't know if
they had the same ones double
Contracting all contracted to fly out
and like helicopters to come to their
thing at a moment's notice oh so These
Guys these these Navy SEALS or whatever
uh on hair trigger alert to be wheeled
up within 90 minutes if the if the new
if the new alarm goes off or something
yeah one of them has people at his plane
all the time ready you know you've got
to go yeah to one of two or three
different locations like geez and then
but the thing of that I asked them was
why do you think your Navy Seals are
going to protect you once the event is
what they call it once the event happens
you know you're you're your money is
going to be worthless at that point even
if it's Bitcoin right so why are they
not just going to take over you
definitely light red Machiavelli 101.
like how do you how do you take care of
you and they hadn't really considered
that and then they start once they start
musing on what they could do like oh I
could be the only one who knows the
combination to the safe you know where
that where the food is kept it's like oh
so Navy Seals have never tried to get
Secrets out of anyone before that would
really stump them you're right it was
like well they was talking about
implants that would be controlling who
gets to go where in the compound and
worst case they could be used for
discipline it's like oh right Navy Seals
are going to really respond well to
being disciplined to the equivalent of
shock collars so it was uh uh it was
just ludicrous so for me it just showed
uh the the sort of
almost middle school science fiction
logic of of their scenarios and that it
made me question the sort of the the
visions of all of the tech Bros these
kind of you know whatever they are these
kind of uh meta Modern Blue Sky game be
you know all these uh theories about
kind of rising from the Chrysalis of
matter is pure Consciousness or you know
uh adapting to this great metaphorical
future thing and I started to see them
all in the same bucket as people who
were you know
for time for centuries afraid of women
afraid of nature you know afraid of the
unpredictability of real life and
actively fantasizing about the
opportunity to escape to level up you
know to go as Peter Thiel would say from
zero to one or Zuckerberg to go meta you
know or or uh Kurzweil to put his brain
up in Silicon everyone wants to go up
and it's like I don't it's not a theory
of change that I can really uh take that
seriously so do you think that some of
these guys secretly uh hoping waiting
almost praying for this to happen in a
way does it justify their worries and
concerns does it offer them a better
kind of life in in some ways
well I think they're impatient for it to
happen partly because they've been
raised on Western narrative you know on
Marvel movies you gotta have your end
game right or it or it doesn't what did
I pay my money for if I don't get the
end game if I don't get the thing the
the moment partly it's because they've
got a kind of techno solutionist bias
where they're used to just just reboot
or you know a version two version three
you know let's go from web one to web
two let's go for web 2 to web three they
just want to kind of that that urge to
kind of reboot up there and
and yeah it's it's a a
way to to
realize that it it's I mean I think of
Steve Bannon kind of the same way
although for different very different
reasons you know tear this thing down
this thing is corrupt I mean he's scared
of these he's the one of the only ones
who takes all these teal and musk and
the technocrats and great reset people
he's the only one who takes them really
seriously
um and and and you hear it you know that
oh no these techno guys and Epstein and
and implants and gates with Nanobots and
all they believe these uh technological
systems are really coming and that we
the people through blood and soil are
gonna fight that thing but it's that
same that what they share in common is
this urge to tear this thing down you
know when I see musk the way musk
relates to Biden and government and all
that stuff it's like oh come on we don't
need that we have a blockchain that or a
blue sky or a program and and we could
be free to be you and me in a totally
different for fractal that you you know
old woke Democrats can't understand
let's just do it pedal to the metal you
know that's sort of that drive
what about sea studying did you have a
look at that have you spent much time
researching this
under one hand it'd be kind of fun you
know let's go to the Sea you know build
my own little raft with solar-powered
propulsion and and eat fish and grow
Alfalfa or whatever and and what's
Alfalfa you know it's like you put it on
it's a salad green or something I think
whatever all right one of those I mean I
thought it was a type of algae okay cool
yeah or you could do algae web even
better right like blue green algae or or
or uh what's that stuff that people eat
I forgot what it's called now but
there's all those little yeah we could
make that stuff I mean the the real
fantasy though is
for frictionless community that I can
float my sort of hexagonal raft to the
nation of my choice and attach to it and
now I'm in this nation of people all on
their rafts and we have our own system
of government and we approve cloning but
don't approve abortion and we do approve
this and that and these are our rules we
have a blockchain we have our own
currency and all that and then if this
country starts to have a rule or
something I don't like I could detach my
raft and you know solar power float to
that country over there they got the
roles that I want so it's that it's that
idea of of a Nation with no skin in the
game with no exit cost you know it's
like you could change as easily as you
could change your cell phone company you
can change your your nation and um I
don't think real Community works that
way I think you do
gotta be with people who believe stuff
you don't like and there's some rules
that you disagree with and was was part
of that not the justification for the
way that the United States was put
together though that you basically do
have 50 kind of small countries all put
together yes you're sharing a a currency
in a language but broadly it is you know
you don't like it here you can move
there what what's the what's wrong with
somebody who wants to just up and leave
when stuff doesn't go the way they like
well any Federation is like that it's
certainly fine for my Mastodon servers
you know you're on one and talking that
you're like I don't want to be on this
one I'm going to go over on that one but
they're all Federated so that you can
still follow anybody in any one of them
no I mean in in certainly in a digital
realm or in a brand loyalty it makes
total sense as a way of of
fostering
long-term difficult relationships
between people over time
I don't know I I I don't I don't have a
problem with frictionless if people want
to change their town every week and move
around it's just what is it biased
toward so when I look at the plan when I
hear them describing it if you don't
like this you'll just float away it's a
free market version of
Civics and I I get it and there's cool
things about it but to me it betrays
what it's all really about it's I don't
like the rules on your country which
they don't right we can't just develop
Tech I'm not allowed to do all the
cloning I want and there's these
regulations about genetic engineering so
I'm going to take my ball my billion
dollars and go and make my own freaking
country out in the middle of the ocean
you can't do anything to me and I have
to do it out in the ocean because I
don't yet have enough money to get my
rocket ship my blue origin up to Mars
and terraform that place but when I can
I will you know see ya
I I understand the place that this comes
from I think you know like personal
sovereignty independent individual
agency all of these things are things
that almost everybody that I respect is
pushing forward at the moment you know
it's the anti the antithesis of the
victimhood narrative at the moment it's
taking control and responsibility for
the things that you do I think that's
pretty much a universal good yeah I also
understand what happens when you take
that too far and it encourages people to
not properly integrate into the local
group that's around them like you know
you could say and I see this
particularly amongst dads particularly
particularly amongst wealthy dads that
are Maybe
late 40s to 50s they have spent a long
time building companies and acquiring
wealth and then they get to this stage
and there's something about it where
they they seem to kind of say [ __ ] you a
little bit to the rest of the world and
it's like a
a retreat in a way it's more
individualistic it's more atomized it's
it's like me and my family and [ __ ]
everybody and everything else and I do I
do see this I do understand what happens
if you take that personal sovereignty
thing and you roll it Forward across
many tens of millions of dollars and a
lot of resources and a lot of spare time
and a family that you don't want to have
hurt I I understand how yeah how that's
about yeah or a family you don't even
want to be with anymore for that matter
or you want to air gap yourself from
everybody including your ex-wife right
yeah or your current wife yeah um but
I'll tell you you know and I haven't
said this before and I'm I'm in a lot of
discussions about the origins of this
and it's it's on the one hand it is and
traditionally I kind of blame it on
libertarianism and the West Coast uh the
West Coast kind of libertarianism that
dovetailed so perfectly with techno
solutionism it was John Barlow telling
us you know the Declaration of
Independence of cyberspace you know
nations of the world get off here this
is for us and we didn't realize if you
get government away corporations grow
and and roam free so there is that that
narrative is is an important one and I
don't minimize it and I still feel like
oh damn when wired came that and blue
Mondo 2000 out of the water you know
when when the business guys came and
turned the net from our great
psychedelic Rave space into this [ __ ]
techno-capitalist nightmare it's like
wait a minute this wasn't why are you
taking all this stuff public why are we
having IPOs why are we after eyeball
hours and all that so there's that but
the thing I haven't said and it's
probably too dangerous to say and I
might get canceled and whatever but
um it's also
an almost necessary or it's an almost
inevitable response to Marxism you know
and Hannah Arendt wrote about this in in
the banality of evil and in other places
that Marxism not workers rights but
Marxism as a kind of a a scientific
version of workers rights has as a kind
of an end game this
total equality it's like I understand we
don't want anyone to be deathly poor
that they're that they're sick and can't
have a but
there's poverty there's inequality
that's sort of what happens in in a
society and this this almost scientific
desire to annihilate all forms of
inequality is itself provocative to the
self-sovereign individual right so uh
and you could look at it on the on the
personal level if you see oh my God
everybody's getting canceled for
everything here and there and there and
there and then I think back you know
there was a girl in middle school I mean
before sex or anything like that there
was a girl in Middle School
that my friends convinced I really had a
crush on her and and kind of told her
then my friends convinced me no no it's
not cool you're going to be hated and
not liked and whatever and I I ditched
her for no reason
that you know I mean that's as bad as
I'm I'm
there's all sorts of equivalents of that
that a whole bunch of guys look at a
cancellation movement and think someday
it's going to be me they're going to
come for me or those of us who are
involved in social justice understand
that the social justice terms that we
use in one year may be obsolete in the
next year and the video of us saying the
thing that was appropriate in one year
then becomes
bad word to use the next year or or the
year after so when when people sense
that that there's this moving Target
that they will never be able to meet and
there's no wiggle room there's no uh uh
uh a place for reconciliation or apology
or uh or error
um it does it it activates a a reverse
poll to something
you know total self-sovereignty and
anti-woke and [ __ ] that Manila I want
any work I want to use bad words and you
look at a musk and you're and it's and
it's on that level it's refreshing uh
he's not taking no [ __ ] from nobody he's
gonna you know call Hillary this and
call AOC that and haha and he's not
afraid he's like pre-canceled
um so there's and and there's that
energy behind a lot of these Escape
fantasies I think of like wait a minute
society's getting too woke so when you
hear like Jim rutt who's a really smart
um um he's a Smart Systems theorist he
used to be the head of Santa Fe
Institute and he's the main guy behind
something called game B which is a place
like where the idea is we're all living
in gay may now which is regular
competitive Society but we can Elevate
and go to game B which is the next phase
of human existence and he always talks
about the obstacle to it as those woke
people those goddamn woke people and so
I I understand
but wokeism as an extension of Marxism
and Marxism as
um
a version of Marxism as this trigger for
people to then do this other thing uh
okay so the reason that the gym rut yeah
yeah the reason that Jim rutt is saying
that the
difficulty in moving from game a and
descending to game B being the woke
movement is not any of the first order
effects of wilkism it's the second order
effect of the knee-jerk reaction when
the pendulum swings back against wilkism
which is
hyper-individualistic it's atomized it's
dumer optimism it's Elon Musk [ __ ]
posting his way through AOC it's Q Anon
it's all of this stuff right well he
might be I don't know whether he's a
first or second order effect of it but
yeah
um I think he's more in the camp of
partly game B is to get away from this
stuff I mean I think he's a first order
he's in the first order effect of it but
yeah and it's It's Tricky and it's
because
and again this is really hard to say
because it makes it sound like there's
an equivalence and there's not I don't
mean to equate right and left or Trump
and AOC or anything like that there are
different degrees there's way different
levels of stuff I mean I would way
rather you know be in aoc's country than
than Trump's country but there's uh
the problem is not just Trump and his
cronies they are the they are the
figures they are not the ground they're
the images they're not the atmosphere
it's the atmosphere itself that it's as
if the air we breathe has become
totalitarian has become that in this is
this extremist thing it's like an
accelerant like we're not breathing air
we're breathing nitrous or something you
know like Knight just does do in
automobiles right and everything is is
Amplified and accelerated and extreme
and I feel like any political movement
any cultural movement now on whatever
side of the political Spectrum it is
ends up I'm kind of revved up
um partly by the digital media
environment that we're in and partly by
whatever whatever this thing is going on
um in in the air that there are these
currents that are moving things around
and and then you've got guys like um
you have some Wizards out there like
Bannon is a wizard musk is a wizard that
make it look like they're the ones
actually doing making these currents but
they're not they're just uh seeing them
and riding on them you know I don't
think Trump was was did anything I think
Trump was more like Charlie Sheen you
know there was this kind of standing
wave of culture that was happening and
he just jumped in it it was like ah you
know so we look at him as the picture
but but it's not it he just he just he
just uh embodied the phenomenon it is
very interesting to think about this
this knee-jerk reaction that's a model
that I think I'm gonna try and try and
use as I continue forward I mean when
you consider the prepping movement's
been around for a long time right you
know people predicting the end of the
world and
trying to avoid alien abduction or
whatever it might be and then Doomer
optimism which I'm not sure if you're
familiar with
uh is a
that's the middle ground version of this
and then the end game is the
billionaires and I had a look at there's
that company called vivos they sell
luxury underground apartments in
converted Cold War Munitions storage
facilities and missile silos so that's
that's taking it up to Absolute extreme
yeah swords to plowshares baby it's it's
almost biblical right except it's not
really plowshares it's shorts to
shelters uh yeah I mean they sell them
there's a the ones I like are in Europe
they're called like opinium or something
those look nice they have swimming pools
and saunas and things
do I have to wait until the end of the
world or is there an opportunity for me
to just go now I know that's the thing
can't we just go now but not have to do
it underground so one of the guys yeah
they but there was one you know one of
them and it's interesting because one of
them was from a very Christian company
called I forgot what Rising S
corporation and they build build um they
take shipping containers and stick them
under the ground originally for people
for like tornado shelters and Fallout
shelters and things like that then when
the the rich people got into the
apocalypse bus they're like oh there's a
good business so instead of just putting
one one train car down there you know
they'll put like 12 shipping containers
all networked together and they've got
pools they got heated pools and fake
daylight and and I I one of that was one
of the guys I was talking to was doing
one of those and I was like dude it's
like my neighbor has a pool not right
down there they have a pool and there's
always a truck in front of there
bringing some other part or Gizmo that
broke like a heater or a regulator you
know a thermostat thing like where are
you gonna get that where's that guy in
your plan where's all the you have a 3D
printer making the parts for your pool
you know can they do that yet of course
not and he's like oh he opened his
little moleskin book he's like parts for
pool I'm like okay you do really well
work this out buddy that's funny oh yeah
so what looking at what you know about
the current approach that the super rich
have when it comes to saving themselves
from the apocalypse that's coming what
are the most fragile elements of their
preparation
um security definitely
you know they they any of them that are
Land Based
we can go take them over there's more of
us even if you know a thousand of us get
shot on our way in plus if we've got
motorcycle gangs with Uzis or whatever
they have I think these are very
penetrable
these are penetrable uh some of them
have farms and [ __ ] so there's that the
ones that are totally locked away
um they're agriculture systems are are
totally self-contained a lot of them
have like their topsoilers in these
little rubber tubes and then you try to
grow I mean have you ever seen somebody
doing vertical farming at home or
whatever you get a bad batch it's like
you get a bad panel and you just take it
out and go get some topsoil and build
another one or you can't do that when
you're locked away you know or what do
you do you go out with a the crew with a
couple of guys with machine guns to run
and find some more sterile topsoil but
of course you got the nuclear fallout
and the you know zombies and the Killer
Bees and you know whatever it is out
there that that you're supposed to be
hiding from so the the self-contained
um
Universe the the sort of the thing that
failed with biosphere
um will fail with a lot of these because
they think everything's going to
regenerate
um so those are the those and and that
they're not really sealed from germs and
I mean covid got everywhere somehow you
know eventually somebody's bringing
something or a bird's gonna poop and you
know you're gonna You're Gonna Catch
whatever people have as I see it these
things are
they're so brittle they're they're
brittle from the get-go they're they're
brittle they're a brittle approach to
survival if you talk to a real prepper
and I have Smart Preppers
they're they're preparedness plans
always involve the communities in which
they're embedded they prep by teaching
people in their communities how to prep
they do foraging classes and farming
classes and self-defense classes because
they realize we've the only way to be
prepared is to be prepared together not
prepared alone the lone prepper does not
does not survive
how comfortable or uncomfortable is it
for you spending time around people that
have both the
desire means and resources to be able to
enact something like this I had a
conversation a little while ago with a
friend and he mentioned that he'd spoken
to it someone that's maybe in a similar
position to the gentleman that had paid
you to go and teach them how to survive
the end of the world and this guide said
uh I'm an apex predator Apex predictors
don't need to concern themselves about
what happens to their prey and this guy
as far as my friend was concerned was
like he meant it like he genuinely
believes that he is close to the
absolute top of the tree of this entire
planet and that the externalities are
kind of the same as stepping on a bug
and that story struck with me that was
like two years ago that I heard that
story it really stuck with me because I
think wow there's there's people out
there that that have that kind of
mindset and that have the resources to
be able to uh live the philosophy that
that mindset creates
yeah I mean that's the mindset that I'm
really writing about in in my book I
mean that's really what it's about you
know most of the people want to know oh
you wrote this book how do I how do I
survive what are your Tech what are your
tips and techniques I'm like no no I'm
kind of trying to undermine it's called
Escape fantasies of the tech of the tech
billionaires but you're right it comes
from you know and that's why I look at
really two strains one is is a certain
thread of the Scientific Revolution you
know which was Francis Bacon and you
know Francis Bacon was sort of the
father of empirical science and he's
credited with saying that the the
purpose of of empirical science the
promise is that it it will allow us to
take Nature by the forelock hold her
down and submit her to our will
okay great so science is basically a
rape fantasy right we're gonna take
Nature by the hair hold her down and and
have our way with her that's what
science will let us do again it's that
Apex predator's understanding yes you
are man you are man you know so we can
take we are in charge of nature we can
dominate nature and as any truly
enlightened person realizes that's
that's not even the way you get power
much less
um the way you survive you don't
dominate nature you learn to work with
the patterns of nature the patterns of
your body you know some of the stuff
that you've talked about too about the
natural cycles of of waking and sleeping
and if you learn the patterns you you
ride them and you become strong and
healthy and all that as opposed to
trying to defeat the patterns of nature
with what with speed and sleeping pills
and Prozac and you know because you
can't
recognize you because you refuse to
submit to the day and night I heard that
Seasons sorry there's Seasons you can't
change them Go With It Just Go With It
um it's okay it's gonna be okay sun will
come out again
um so there's that and then the the
capitalism
is the other one you know you talked
about externalities and externalities
are built into Colonial capitalism in
order for the markets to grow which they
have to grow because we're on this
Central currency interest bearing
economic operating system in order for
it to grow we got to take over more
places enslave their people and extract
their resources and those are
externalities the enslaved people the
pollution but if we have technology
which is the sort of the latest part of
this puzzle we can build a car that goes
fast enough to escape from its own
exhaust there will be externalities but
those are other people's problems you
know and if it's too much if the whole
world gets filled up with the exhaust
then well
then we go and we get blue origin and we
go to the next one
I remember having a conversation ages
ago with a astrophysicist that
specialized in detecting alien
civilizations so there's seti and then
there's meti as well and meti is
messaging extraterrestrial intelligence
and there's a lot of uh big questions
being asked around where the Met is even
a good idea in the first place and I
asked what are some of the most likely
uh signs that other civilizations would
have because some would be underwater
some would be a silicon based some might
have thoughts that take decades to go
through etc etc and he said that global
warming that the uh use of any type of
energy is inevitably going to cause kick
out of pollution into the environment
which has to change the environment
there are only a small number of ways
that you can do stuff like smelting uh
like generating any kind of energy and
the externalities that you get from that
and it made me think like maybe it maybe
it is the case that we can't techno
Utopia our way out of this I have some
friends that believe that the solution
to the side effects of Technology isn't
more technology I know that you talk
about this uh but I know increasingly um
I know kind of a little bit less certain
about that
I know and then it's funny I was talking
with um uh Tyson yonkaporta who's this
really smart
um
Australian
um
an indigenous person and scholar and um
he says he thinks that Western
Civilization is in a state of depression
after having seen the movie Avatar
because Avatar is the opposite right
Avatar is a civilization that is
basically expending no energy Beyond
you got sort of what they eat and and
you know the beyond the their their
metabolism of their bodies you know in
harmony with nature and
it's this picture of something that we
could I can't imagine how we could you
know go forward to that I mean I was
going to say get back to that maybe you
can't go back ever but how could we move
forward and I I do believe that the the
the most sustainable and most fun
society that we could live in would look
a bit like a permaculture Farm or
something and there would be less Tech I
mean I'm not anti-tech I love Tech and
it's been fun it's been fun but
I love you know nature and people and
flesh and stuff more you know and
I don't know I I
if you know if we could
um degrowth is a bad word I won't say
that if we could sort of unwind simplify
a bit simplify yeah there's nicer ways
of saying it we would
um if we move to a situation where we
don't need to to have the GDP grow every
year Well we don't need to do more just
for the sake of maintaining the balance
sheet but we only did more that we
needed to do more in order to to feed
and clothe and care for other people
um
we could get rid of a lot of a lot of
unnecessary
stuff you know all the plastic that
we're buying at Walmart and throwing
away and you know there's just I get it
it's good for the economy that if
everyone on the block has a lawnmower
it's better for the economy than if one
person has a lawnmower that we all share
but it's a nicer Society if we have one
lawnmower on the Block and everyone
shares it yeah so there's the ego which
is the embroidered embedded growth
obligation right which is what you're
talking about the GDP needs to continue
each year Etc yeah it feels to me like
there's an Eco as well which is an
embedded Comfort obligation that humans
never want to regress back to a less
comfortable type of life than the one
that they're in at the moment
yeah and but then we gotta also then
think about how are we defining comfort
you know I guess it's more comfortable
to sit in this Costco chair than on a
rock right but
there's
I don't know there's there's comfort
there's many kinds of comfort well I
mean it's less less Comfort would come
from not having spinal issues you know
in your 50s 60s and 70s because you've
not spent a ton of time sat down it
would come from suffering less with
diabetes because you were moving around
a lot more but the problem that you have
is that what is good for you in the long
term often feels difficult in the short
term so you'd switch out to sea in Eco
for comfort for convenience you know and
and convenience obligation like why is
it that I should walk to the store to
get my 10 000 steps in for today when I
can Amazon Prime it and it'll be here by
7 PM why would I do that and it it takes
I always think about this we've got a me
and my housemate have got a cold tub
outside right like we've had to buy a
five thousand dollar piece of kit
so that I can find discomfort I elect to
find discomfort and inject it into my
daily life because my natural existence
is so bereft of anything that looks even
remotely difficult right I have to go
out of my way to try and find podcasts
or books that are going to mentally tax
me I have to go out of my way to go into
a building which has a selection of
handles with weights attached to them
because normally I don't have to pick
anything up that's heavier than a
sandwich like I'm having to artificially
inseminate so much discomfort into my
life because the Eco that embedded
convenience obligation continues to get
more and more and more convenient over
time and humans often mistake a
convenient or enjoyable experience for a
worthwhile one and until I I don't think
that that's fixable I simply don't think
it's fixable to be able to get humans to
look past this is difficult now but good
in the long term even if you'd given it
to our cave caveman ancestors even if
you've gone within one generation you
can go from rocks and fire and a wheel
to all of the stuff that we've got now
even they wouldn't have wanted to go
back because it is a race to the bottom
of the convenience stem
right although some civilizations didn't
you know that lasted a long time in a
sort of homeostasis uh it has would they
have ever got they wouldn't have ever
stepped into that technological
advancement and then regressed back
right they simply wouldn't probably need
to step forward right yeah right but of
course because they didn't move into the
technological advancement they got
clobbered by Colonial civilizations that
did right see ya
sorry if one civilization is putting 50
of its effort into Munitions then the
one that's you know not putting any into
it is going to get uh is going to get
killed pretty fast no I hear you I hear
you and the other thing you know is that
technology accelerates that process you
know when Kevin Kelly or any of the you
know technology theorists talk about
tech they always say technology gives us
more Choice it gives us choice but we
haven't yet developed the capacity to
make wise choices we make like you're
saying the convenience the short-term
convenient choice you know and then on
the other end again because of this this
totalitarian environment on the other
end of the spectrum the so-called
long-term thinkers
are thinking about the civilization of
40 trillion Bots spread out through the
universe rather than the AP 800 whatever
8 billion people alive today so they go
so far on the Other Extreme that wait a
minute what about just sort of medium
long term then just the next 500 or a
thousand years you know let's look at
that it's a difficult one man it really
is talk to me about you had this story
about a banker that went to Burning Man
and came back and had seen a different
side of the world yeah what's weird I
get I get invited to these uh these
things they always have the word human
in them you know you know Festival of
the new Humanity or you know the next
level of humans and the whatever I got
invited to one of them and I don't know
why I finally agreed to go to this one
um and it was you know a thing where
they go and you got like uh some some
Shaman gets paid to come and and chant a
bit and you do guided visualizations and
it's all like hedge fund dudes and
bankers and whatever that have like gone
to Burning Man done mushrooms or LSD or
Ayahuasca for the first time and then
they see the light right oh my God I'm
destroying the planet and they come back
and then they want to like process it
with the spiritual people and the
problem is they they have the insight
and then they decide oh
I should be the leader of the climate
change Revolution as if there haven't
been people they don't want to join the
existing climate change things I said to
one of them who was like oh I've got a
lead I'm going to create a new
organization that's going to aggregate
this and that and I'm like well have you
heard of Extinction Rebellion or the
sunrise movement or nature conservancy
there's there's out there it's like well
no and if I haven't heard of them how
good could any of them be
it's like like you weren't freaking
looking I'm telling you this is your
first hour as a newly minted
climatologist
maybe you shouldn't run the thing but
you see this all the time you know even
um bless his heart the owner of the LA
Dodgers uh or former owner this guy
started something called unfinished and
project Liberty it's this giant huge
zillion dollar Foundation to develop a
[Music]
multi-racial open Democratic blockchain
Society and has this conference that
he's doing in New York in this giant
facility and invites everybody and it's
like you don't have to I put their CEO
mentality so they want to run they want
to be in charge of the whole thing you
know so there's like all these kind of
competing future of humanity efforts out
there okay so you're around the I mean
to be for I think that not knowing about
Extinction Rebellion is a good thing as
far as I can see they glue themselves to
the roads in the UK and stop people from
getting to work and don't do very much
else at the moment that seems to be
their primary objective uh well they
were based trying to be based more on
kind of the yellow jackets you know
Citizen councils and all but I mean
there's problems in that but you should
at least understand the existing
territory yes before you're gonna if
you're going to step into a market you'd
usually do some research beforehand I I
mean that the word hubris keeps coming
to mind a lot yeah
that'd be the one yeah and that's why I
mean it's funny and that's why I I I
sound like I'm I don't mean to be an
apologist for right or left or anybody
but they're they're they're hubris is
almost more of a a psychological problem
than than anything else you know it was
like I don't
uh I've read their philosophies and
ideas and I know while there's some
problems in certain ones of them none of
them would be that catastrophically
dangerous if we weren't like in this
frictionless new space of kind of
digital media it's like everything's on
Ice you push in a direction what do you
mean bring that down to earth a little
bit for me I feel like
um
ideologies are more are more dangerous
now because they're not tempered by
community and the real world so you
build an ideology you're building it
okay so Twitter is going to build blue
sky and we'll have this space it's not
real it's meta it's it's
um it's in a different realm or because
of the way things get accelerated and
Amplified in in digital media someone
can say something that okay let's take
some time to unpack it but before
anybody's even taken a moment to unpack
it it's the guys canceled by this group
and becomes the Messiah of that group
and it's like no wait a minute let's
let's let this mature let's discuss this
idea let's
you know so there's no
um I feel like there's no there's no
filter there's no Governor there's no
um
uh there's no way to kind of slow down
or metabolize and work on ideas they
just come out like as if they're fully
hatched and yes and I suppose in that
environment good ideas and bad ideas
have equal uh footing Under the Sun in
terms of how quickly they can go viral
in fact some bad ideas you know I I know
about extinction extinction Rebellion
gluing themselves to the roads I'm I'm
sure well they didn't glue but they sat
there but other people in the UK have
glued yeah people in the UK and in
France have glued themselves to the road
because the reason for that is that the
police have to come over with uh with
like anti-solvent stuff and then slowly
peel their hands up my point being that
uh there are other things that they've
done right but what I know about what my
primary exposure to them is them being
[ __ ] in the middle of a Motorway in
the UK so it is just as easy for
poor philosophies to grab a hold of the
internet in fact it might even be more
because outrage is so clickable uh it
might make it go even quicker all right
given all of this together how how was
this informed the way that you move
through the world because you've been
talking and thinking and writing about
technology for quite a while how are you
dealing with the crushing weight of
existence itself and and not losing your
mind being exposed to all of these ideas
um
for me by trying to slow down
to try to have less hubris myself
um
to I mean I'm on sort of book tour or
something now so I guess I'm talking a
bunch but to sort of talk a little bit
less
um to adopt the the comportment more of
a kind of a country doctor you know I'm
just a local Country Doctor looking at
problems and and offering ideas but not
you know grandstanding great Solutions
um encouraging the a multitude of local
Solutions rather than singular giant
top-down things it's the it's the the
hundred million dollar X prize you know
Geo engineered let's put sulfur
particles in the whatever in that
atmosphere but those are the things that
I'm sort of
um
although all of them are attempting
because you just push a button let's see
um I'm trying to engender a multitude of
small Solutions and give people more
faith in their
um that doing something locally really
does count you know and and trying to
resist scale
and for me it's tricky because if I see
scale as the problem you know as as
in in most cases
if scale is the problem then how do I
operate as like or whatever it is that I
am a writer and thinker not at scale
you know how to and and I don't think I
mean compared to a lot of people I don't
really have scale I mean garyvee has
scale I'm still you know on that in the
twitterverse I'm oh I'm a 60 000 person
which is nice but not one of those
people
um so it's funny on the one hand I I
it's sweet that I worry about scale
operating at my scale I'm like oh no am
I too big am I too powerful you know
it's like okay I'm glad that I'm worried
about it but um when I look at it
objectively I don't think uh that that's
really my uh that's going to be my great
problem
um but yeah and to try to get uh
uh person to person you know every
founder that I can convince that it's
okay to end up with 50 million dollars
instead of five billion dollars is a win
why
why because if they don't feel obligated
to make five or ten billion dollars with
their company then they don't have to
Pivot to something awful and extractive
you know when you hear now Mark
Zuckerberg saying oh I really I'm going
to give back 95 percent of my money I
made on Facebook it's like well what if
you had made Facebook 95 less
manipulative and awful and extractive
you wouldn't have the world would be the
world would be different now that kid
that poor kid plucked out of his
freshman year at Harvard you know by
Peter Thiel or whoever it was and he
transfers parental Authority onto this
venture capitalist and pivots away from
a I just want to make a platform that's
going to help nerds like me get laid to
this you know
data you know data mining nightmare
um
boy
um we'd be living we could be living in
a different world I mean probably
someone else would have done it or would
have happened some other way but
um
yeah it's it's it's scale it's people
being satisfied it's just so hard you
know again it's sort of like your
convenience thing once you get it why
would you go back you know once you have
you know a million and a half Instagram
followers
why would you undo that intentionally
well you also see it's been I mean
Austin at the moment and a lot of the
people here are talking about
homesteading they're talking about
community housing in one form or another
where they're gonna them and nine other
families and their kids are gonna go and
they've got 100 acres of land out in
Lockhart and they're gonna they've been
learning about regenerative farming and
they such and such a certain person's
wife as a teacher and this person is a
doctor and you know we're basically
going to set ourselves up here and I
understand the
impetus because there is a direct line
to draw from what you've just said there
which is kind of this
more simple type of life where you are
looking at slowing down but it doesn't
take much of a change in direction for
that to
fall into the very
um individualistic me and mine versus
the world mentality that we were just
lambasting 10 minutes ago like it's not
that far away at all right and then you
gotta look I mean and and while I
certainly appreciate what those families
want to do I wonder I guess not everyone
can do that right there's not enough
land for everyone to do that we and it's
expensive it's very the only people I
know that are doing that are pretty rich
right so they can go and build an Eco
farm with solar panels and hydroponic
blah blah under the ground and get their
alpacas and goats and all the good stuff
yeah exactly It's Tricky it's like the
guys I know in the tech world who still
go home to their Organic Farms with the
with the with the goats and rudo Steiner
tutors and whatever yeah I I certainly
understand the impetus too but that's
almost a that's a a heavy lift
that's a heavy lift and it may it may go
against some core Simplicity principles
but yeah I mean for me it's just meeting
the people where I live trying to spend
you know less time online more time
helping
you know not assuming I know what's best
for people but what do they what do they
need oh you just you know this woman
needs a lift every Thursday to get
freaking groceries this kid needs a math
tutor you know you do you do what you
can and it embeds you in your community
in a way that um
that feeds your it feeds your heart a
lot better than you know 60 likes on
that tweet you know it really does okay
that's what you're doing on an
individual level and what's what's the
fix on a more macro level is there
anything that can be done or are we just
along for the ride in the slipstream of
billionaires at the moment
foreign
well I mean I think there are things
that could be done one
um I don't think and I know this is
controversial but I don't think that
billionaires truly have our best
interests at heart
a lot of them anyway I think they and
the ones that do don't um the ones that
do are deluded
um so I think that one one thing we can
do is deflate their power by not using
their platforms so much not buying their
stuff so much you know I'm now I'm
checking out Mastodon as you know the a
new it's a
alternative kind of Twitter social
network place that's a Federated
non-profity thing to see just because
it's like I don't know if I want to
support this kind of troll thing
happening on on Twitter and elsewhere
you know I don't want a Tesla either
you know it's not like I know musk is
trying to do good things and uh and
parts of his personality are are quite
benevolent but others it's just brittle
it's a brittle single point of failure
you know and I feel like there's there's
some loose screws there that are that
that may not uh that need to be uh
balanced out with other people doing
other things
um so yeah I guess my my macro solution
is for everyone
um to Avail themselves of opportunities
to you know engage locally to realize
that you know we don't all need opinions
on every big thing I remember when um my
example when uh uh Biden was pulling out
of Afghanistan three or four different
journalists came to me to ask me for
their articles what's your opinion of
Biden's uh Afghan withdrawal strategy
and I'm like I really know nothing about
how you withdraw from a war I just
well just weigh in I can't weigh in I
shouldn't weigh in you know and
everybody's tweeting oh this and that
and the other I'm like how many what if
we just set aside a hundred thousand of
us as the experts in it just one hundred
thousand you know it's like I used to
say you know every time that Britney
Spears would have like a nervous
breakdown they'd be like 100 or 200
camera trucks outside our house I'm like
couldn't we cover this with five camera
trucks and share the feed you know and
maybe take the other 95 and put them in
situations that matter War zones and
learn about other stuff so there's
there's that it's like uh
the the world the big things matter but
we can take the weight off a lot of
these big things we can make
um the the macro problems less brittle
by being more
um self-sufficient I don't mean self but
but Community sufficient locally
sufficient as as places so yeah find
where does your food come from how local
can you get it where's your CSA your
community supported agriculture group
what's going on in your community you
know that that most of us can operate at
that level I think and you know have
like Representatives that work at these
at these uh more macro levels on our
behalf all right Douglas let's bring
this one home why should people go if
they want to check out the stuff that
you do online
um rushcoff.com is me uh teamhuman dot
fm is my lovely podcast
um and check out this new book which is
not um as depressing as it might sound
survival of the richest Escape fantasies
of the tech billionaires which the real
purpose of this book was to be a comedy
to help people laugh if we can laugh at
these guys
um then they're the the whole thing
starts to feel less
scary and and Urgent in that brittle way
and you know what I mean it's just like
oh right I get it they're just silly
don't worry about them they're silly you
know don't don't try to be musk let musk
be musk and you can be you all right
Douglas thank you thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]